Salam aleykoum,
I will present you 5 exercises
very important for the wrestlers.
So let's start with the rope,
Too bent,
back straight and we work only with our arms
30seconds.
We continue the strolls without stopping
with 1 balloon of 5 to 10 kilos,
we will come to touch with the knee every time
and do it as fast as you can.
Now we'll work on the top of the trunk.
Take 1 weight from 10 to 15 kilos
and we'll come and spin it around the head,
well above the shoulders,
10 times left,
10 times right.
We'll work on the top of the trunk again,
we take 1 bar of 20 kilos,
there also the straight back,
we go up to the chin
and we raise
30seconds of coal.
30seconds of recovery,
we start the whole thing again 3 times.